- I think the number
one piece of advice
I have for a 19-year-old
is always patience.
There's a very big difference
between being rich
and being wealthy.
And really normally it's
predicated on people
that are thinking in a
20 or 30 year window
versus people that are thinking
20 or 30 minute window.
You are entering, first of all,
some of the greatest
years of your life.
What you have right now in
timing and circumstance
is this ridiculous, ridiculous
50 month window to
not be practical.
I think there's way too much
wanting it now, now, now
which then leads to
very short-term behavior.
There's no 9-week process
to make money. Right?
There's no seven figure expert
that's going to
show you the way.
It's fucking hard work.
You're 21. You could
stay up 18 hours a day,
You just gotta work
if you want it.
Doing what you love is the
number one thing that
could happen to you.
It's far better than stuff.
And if there's any way that
I could convince you to just
go for it for the next
three or four years
which is going
to eliminate stuff.
So many of you as you build
something are extracting
dollars out so you
can buy things.
A fat whip.
Like dumb fucking watches
instead of putting that
money back in to the business
because you're building
something long term.
As much as I'd love to right now
room up with four of my buddies
and sleep on the floor and
eat fuckin' chicken nuggets
24 hours a day,
it's just not that practical.
Meanwhile, it's ridiculously
practical for you.
This is when you can grind
at your highest levels.
Go and travel.
Go and start that business
that you've always wanted.
The cost that you're
going to put into
trying to do your own thing
is just gonna be your time.
Because time is the biggest,
most valuable
asset in the world.
And so I highly recommend
you take advantage of
the thing that you have
that so few other people have
which is the ability to go
do something right now
and then time to
actually execute it.
You get to live life one time.
Promise me that you understand
that the land grab of happiness
starts right now.
(light music)